it's three days since the water swept
through this place
and they're still finding those who
didn't make it
this is the third one this afternoon so
yeah this has been our toughest day and
uh in another part of the county a few
miles from here another one's recovered
so this is our fourth fourth body this
this afternoon since lunchtime so yeah
tough day
the rescue workers are only just
reaching some parts bridges are down the
electricity the phones and the water too
a little further and we're stopped by
Nolan Allen he's the postmaster for this
community he knows everyone and wants to
show us what it looked like obviously
you're scared I've never seen the water
in my driveway that far it's
unimaginable I don't know you know we're
a tough Bunch we'll help each other
we'll get through this you know we we
all kind of grew up poor we're
pardoned and resilient and
we will manage
have a look at this for a sense of just
how much water was passing through just
this one Valley in such a short space of
time everything that the Deluge of water
was carrying caught by this net around
the sports field and have a look over
here again the playground completely
inundated there must have been 15 20
foot of water passing right through this
low-lying area
they were all all underwater Robert
Fields is born and bred here too alive
but stunned we're seeing so much extreme
weather at the moment aren't we
everywhere that's what I said I mean
it's so extreme that uh
summer the storms have got worse the
rainfalls got worse and then all of a
sudden you'll go to dramatic heat like
it's become a desert we went we went a
month and never had no rainfall and now
after the after that look what
we had 11 inches in climate change
possibly yes there's no piece of good
news in this 20 minutes up the road
hazard is the local city the state
Governor here to offer support and
pledge help it's only six months since
he was doing just the same for
communities hit by record-breaking
unseasonal tornadoes the main thing
about this flood is it's taken
everything from people who didn't have
that much to begin with so it's going to
take real federal and state investment
especially in Rural Water infrastructure
to ultimately withstand these types of
events but what I can say is it whether
it was a tornadoes or this flood it's
going to be hard to build infrastructure
that withstands it and that's the thing
people here are already wondering
whether the place that was home can ever
be again Mark Stone Sky News in
Troublesome Creek Kentucky